Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
January 26,
2015 what's going on?
How are you?
How's it going?
Um,
I am doing this at about 10:41 PM Monday night in Perth,
Australia.
Yeah.
Sorry.
You guys are going to deal with my awful Australian accent.
Um,
and also the shitty recording thing then I'm going to use this week because I
was not lugging my fucking mix up all the way over here.
I remember I had a flat,
I was packing up the mixer and last time I was in Australia I remember I,
I fucking,
I plugged in the mixture and it got it all shorted out even though I had the
thing to uh,
the adapter,
whatever the fuck you call it.
Anyways,
I'm in a fucking hotel room right now.
Yeah.
And it's gross.
I'm going to grow so fucking hotel room right now.
Um,
I don't,
I don't even know where to begin to describe first of all,
the little fucking round coffee table.
I had to wipe the whole thing down from the sticky drinks from the last time.
And uh,
then the fucking,
the,
the rug is just like,
I'm trying to find an area of the rug that isn't stained.
Overrated.
Everybody.
The Hyatt,
the fucking high it.
I remember when I was a kid,
you know,
the fucking hired,
even like a Hilton was considered nice.
Now granted I grew up in a family that,
you know,
a number of times a month we had chipped beef on toast or chicken,
Allah King for dinner,
the scallop potatoes and ham.
It's just before the food network.
So whatever,
whatever the fuck recipes were handed down or on the back of a fucking Rice
Krispie box,
that's what she ate.
If you think about some of the shit,
your head,
oh yeah,
this fucking
hm.
Goulash,
Hungarian Goulash.
That was actually good.
Then we had this other shit and my mother used to put these fucking
okay
noodles in it.
And one day my older brother told me they were actually worms.
And every time I went to either it'd be like fucking gag.
And My mother didn't give a shit.
She make me finish it.
I can't believe,
I can't remember the name of it anyways,
whatever.
But back in the day,
you know,
a height and the Hilton more nice.
Now I don't know what happened.
I don't think they've bought a rug much less shampooed one each time I'm
thinking I'm staying at the Hyatt.
I always thought the Hyatt,
this is going to be great.
It's still stuck in my head like way back in the fucking day
places a Shital.
Um,
anyways,
but I am excited to be out here.
This is the furthest into a Australia that I've ever been.
Nice.
14 hour flight to Sydney and then uh,
we landed and
okay.
Fucking went into a hotel.
Yeah.
Hung out for part of the day and then I had to do,
um,
some big talk show.
I can't even remember the name of it.
I'm so fucking jet liked.
It was weird.
We uh,
this is how we saved the thing.
I went down into a conference room in the hotel and they had me sitting in the
room and then another room,
they had the camera that I just look into and talk and um,
that person in there was in a room with the light shut out.
So I look like some crazy person when my wife came in because I was sitting
there with the light on me talking into a dark room and I'm trying to be
pleasant,
but it's actually a really fun show.
I wish I could have done it live.
So,
um,
anyway,
so I'll be letting you guys know my fucking adventures over here as I go.
Like I said,
I'm starting off here in Perth,
I believe the next night is in Melbourne,
Melbourne,
however the fuck you say it.
And um,
then Brisbane and then Sydney,
and then I'm done.
That's going to take a week.
And then I'm over to New Zealand and up to Singapore,
Hong Kong and then the fucking Mumbai,
India,
then over to New York to go do the,
uh,
the Patrice O'Neal benefit.
So there you go.
Let's can be my God damn week.
Um,
yeah.
All right,
the fuck can I talk about other than just being our God damn plane for the last
fucking day of my life,
where do we begin?
Where do we begin?
Did anything happen this week?
I don't know if you guys saw this week I was on the bill Maher show.
Um,
I don't think I've ever felt so dumb in my life.
You know,
I felt like when I was on Bill Maher show,
I felt like I,
if I went on ESPN and I didn't watch sports,
that's what it felt like.
Everybody's throwing out these fucking stats.
It was like fantasy football,
except they were talking about terrorism or jails or something.
I don't even know.
MMM.
Did the Larry Wilmore show to the first one had a great time on that one.
And that was another one.
It's politician from New Jersey was just firing out these fucking stallion,
well 85,
but said a black bales a day.
They don't have enough toothpicks in their life.
And,
uh,
you know,
if you're a white male,
you give that plenty of everybody nodding and a Grad,
no fucking idea what anybody was talking about.
And you've probably seen what bill,
you know,
you're dumb,
you're not,
you know,
uh,
meet the press kind of fucking person either on a real or a fake news show.
Why the fuck would you go do those gigs?
Because everybody,
I am promoting a movie that comes out January 30th called black or white,
that stars Kevin Costner,
Octavius Spencer and was written by Mike binder and directed by Mike binder.
And um,
had a great time working on that thing.
And you know,
the classic Hollywood didn't want to make it.
Kevin Costner loved the story and he's worked with Mike binder before a movie
called upside of anger and Costner said,
fuck it,
we're going to make this movie.
And he ended up putting up his own money.
So,
um,
if you have the time and you have,
you know,
20th 30 close friends,
if he could drag them out to the local Cineplex and,
uh,
buy a ticket,
watch it legally and that type of thing,
that would be awesome.
I would really appreciate it's called black or white.
I actually play a lawyer.
I play Kevin Costner's lawyer Anthony Mackey's in it may come on and soon to be
star a Jillian Astellas in it.
I mean,
it's just,
it's a veritable who's who except for me.
Somehow I snuck in there.
Um,
should I tell the story?
Bill,
how did you get the part in that movie?
Uh,
you know what the Conan O'brien show,
I was on Conan and running my Yap in my binder.
I had a friend who was watching and said,
hey,
you gotta see this guy?
This guy's funny binder watched it and said,
hey,
you know what?
That's the guy that's Rick Reynolds and I didn't even have to audition for it.
And I fucking went out to New Orleans when we shot it.
And I had no idea what I was getting myself into as far as,
uh,
I'm trying to think when I even read the fucking thing,
when I even read the script,
I think I read it as I was flying out there,
you know,
cause that's where I am in this business.
If you say I have a movie,
I say yes before you even tell me what it's about.
Speaking of which,
I had another one that came out.
I actually did a Zombie servers.
It's a movie about beavers that turned into zombies.
Okay.
And if that doesn't get your ass off the couch,
I don't think anything will,
um,
you know,
people trying to give me shit about that movie,
like Xom view too.
Like we didn't know that it was a joke going into it.
A friend of mine,
Jordan,
Ruben,
I used to do a stand up with him like 20 fucking years ago in New York,
called me up and said,
hey bill,
I'm uh,
doing this movie.
Um,
it's fucking over the top.
It's crazy.
It's ridiculous.
So I was wondering if you would just do a one scene in it.
And I said yes.
And I did a scene with somebody else who's in disguise,
who's actually super famous and I'm,
I'm actually hearing really good things about that thing.
But fucking radio guys like to break my balls about it.
Like I called up,
uh,
WBCN in Boston,
touch her enrich show,
morning show,
touch.
It was breaking my balls about it.
You know,
people see it.
It's,
it's a red flag.
You know,
you got a movie called Xom beavers.
They start looking at you like,
Bill,
did you fucking,
did you blow a guy in this?
Did you do a little bit of porn?
Um,
but whatever.
Uh,
so those are the two,
but black or white comes out January 30th.
I know I'm whoring myself out right out of the gate,
but if you guys would go see,
it'd be really,
really important.
It's a great movie,
great story.
And a lot of these kinds of movies don't get made anymore because nobody pays
for movies anymore,
which is why movies,
either they have like a fucking $500,000 budget or a 500 million because they're
either like not going to invest a lot of money anymore,
or they're going to try to make something like those transformers superhero
fucking movies because they're betting on the fact that you're going to be like,
well,
I gotta go see that at the theater.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno how the whole fucking thing works out.
But you know the deal,
everybody steals everything now.
People put the fucking money up.
So who knows what I'm sweating when it's,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
let's see what the fuck happened this week.
Now this is the off week,
the fucking off week between the AFC and NFC championship games and uh,
and the Superbowl.
So,
you know,
there's never anything to talk about.
So this week they had the whole stupid deflate gate thing,
which I don't even really want to talk about it.
It was so fucking stupid.
You know what I mean?
It was almost like ESPN should have got sued.
Okay.
Oh,
whatever.
You know,
you're not supposed to cry.
Like you're not supposed to yell fire in a crowded movie theater.
That's literally what they were doing.
It was the stupidest fucking the cultural loss by 38 God damn points.
You know,
it's funny,
some guy on ESPN,
one of those science guys actually uh,
you know,
did this whole scientific experiment thing,
um,
to see if uh,
I'll actually post this video and I always say this,
but this time I actually will to see if it was an advantage.
It actually turned out to be a slight disadvantage.
The ball got there like a split second later and they said it was enough for a
defender to get a fingertip more in the way of the path of the ball.
I mean it was so fucking stupid.
I swear to God,
man.
I'm trying to come up with the theory here.
I just think
generally speaking,
people are sick of the Patriots and they fucking hate bill Belichick.
And I know right now that you guys are going to roll your eyes and whatever.
I understand that you like,
well this guy's a fucking patriots fan.
I don't want to hear it but we'll just hear me out here.
This is what I love about bill Bellacheck is even in the press conference after
the game and the press conference before his next game,
it's already part of his game plan.
Everybody always sits there and they talk about how he's so boring.
I hate listen these fucking idiots on sports radio.
They tried to say that he's a joy list man cause he just goes up there and
they'd be like,
hey you got,
you got Seattle coming up for you know,
well what do you think about them yet?
You guys are favored.
Do you think you can beat him?
And I'll just be like,
oh yeah.
All right.
Yeah
I know their work kind of work cut out for ourselves.
He would do that if you were playing like the fucking Tampa Bay Buccaneers and
other great team.
I know it's going to be a tough game.
Got Out,
work cut out for us.
He knows what he's doing.
Okay.
Because sports
media,
they're,
they're lazy.
They're pieces of shit.
And they fucking take whatever you say.
And they only,
they only fucking take a clip of it and they twisted it around and his bulletin
board material for the other team or creates a fucking controversy and,
and distraction and the locker room.
So he gives them nothing so they don't like him.
So they're looking to take the piss out of him.
You know who the media loves,
they love a guy like Rex Ryan.
Okay.
Who's gonna fucking come up and just be like,
we're gonna win the Super Bowl.
I wrote it on a bus,
right,
right there.
Rex Ryan will write 16 articles for you in one fucking one press conference.
He's going to give you your whole fucking season.
And as a writer,
you don't even have to work.
You just put your feet up.
All right?
Either he does it and he's like,
Babe Ruth calling the home run shot or re sales and we get to take the piss out
of him.
Done Bill Pella check gives them nothing.
We make some fucking work.
It makes them actually watched the Goddamn game.
Um,
that was the biggest non fucking story I've ever heard.
And uh,
you know,
I'm over here.
I went on a New York post.com and I saw how Richard Sherman was kind of
mentioning,
trying to suggest that we have this fucking special relationship with the
commissioner.
I love how people just can't see the dirt bags shit that they're doing.
Do you know the Seattle Seahawks?
I've had the most people test positive for,
for performance enhancing drugs since 2011,
including Richard Sherman who also tested positive.
And then he said,
oh,
it was a banned substance.
And uh,
I took a sip off of,
of,
of another player's drink,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
I sipped it.
I didn't know it was in there.
So he got out of it.
Now I'm going to choose to believe them.
Okay.
A Fike ain't choose to believe him.
Why can't he give us the fucking benefit of the doubt?
Really?
That's why it's in there.
You took a sip of your buddies drink.
Okay.
Who fucking Mister Blonde,
who then did the time for you?
And he did it like a man is going to come in here
and decide on of the fucking blue,
um,
give me a fucking break.
Okay.
Seattle Seahawks with that Goddamn stadium that makes it dead.
Their crowd sound louder than it is.
Is that cheating your own fucking coach who got busted so bad in the NCAA,
they actually took a championship away from the guy and this is the fucking
thing.
I'm not a Seahawks fan.
It,
I don't give a fuck about any of that shit.
I don't give a shit of Richard Sherman was hurt.
He did a fucking cycle to get through it.
I don't give a fuck.
I think they ought to be able to do it.
I said that our bill,
Martha fucking NFL players ought to be able to take steroids and the other
people smoke weed after the fucking game.
They gotta be able to heal up their and fucking,
you know,
smoke a little weed,
take away some of the pain.
And there's actually arguments out there that say in the medicinal purposes of
the fucking drug could actually,
you know,
combat Alzheimer's and this new study saying that,
I don't know if it's fucking true,
but I just think if you're going to like beat the shit out of your body,
these fucking Adonises that with two fingers could throw me across the room in
their twenties and in their forties couldn't fucking beat me in a foot race,
you know,
across a fucking hotel lobby.
I mean,
I just feel like these guys,
the damage that they do to their bodies,
okay.
It shortens their lives and the quality of life that they're going to have when
they are alive.
Like I really think that they ought to be able to like steroids or it's almost
like medicine.
I Dunno.
That's just my feeling.
Hey,
you want to build a fucking stadium that makes you crowd louder than it is.
That's not against the rules,
but it's kind of a,
what the fuck.
Considering that Seattle was unbeatable at home and was pretty fucking human on
the road for a couple of years now.
I still don't even give a shit about that.
And as far as that,
Pete Carroll breaking all those fucking rules to the point that they took away a
Heisman trophy,
Hannah national championship,
do you know all sneaky Pete
fucking sitting there telling Mark Sanchez Sanchez that he was leaving college
too soon and then all of a sudden the NCA Hayes at the front door and he sneaks
out the back door like a fucking rat and abandoned all those goddamn kids that
you know,
he told when they signed their scholarships that he wasn't fucking going
anywhere.
He saved his own ass and he ran out the back fucking door.
And you know what?
That's division one college football.
That's how it's fucking done.
I don't give a fuck.
I look at Pete Carroll like he just,
he got caught.
Okay.
You know,
he might've been a little worse or a little less.
Who the fuck knows?
But just the way it works,
the way it fucking works.
Okay.
So the same way you defensive back grabs a handful of Jersey and then the
announcer's go,
hey,
you know,
if you can get away with it,
good for you.
It's the same fucking thing.
So you've got all that shit going on.
This is what kills me to Seattle is actually going to be riding into the
Superbowl wearing the white hat,
which is fucking hilarious to me.
Okay.
Cause they're just as filthy as anybody else,
including the fucking patriots.
Give me a fucking break.
Yeah.
Do you realize these people who actually sit there and call the Patriots
cheaters,
do you realize that's your entire fucking argument is based on Eric Mann,
Jeanie and fucking gym or say,
okay.
Not exactly the most upstanding citizens.
I know I've talked about Jim or say before,
but I'll talk about the guy again.
That guy could not beat the fucking patriots.
His team could not beat the Patriots 10 years ago.
We fucking manhandled is Seavers during this game.
He bitched about it.
Peyton manning about it to the refs after the game,
the wrestle like whatever it was illegal.
The fucking pro bowl comes along.
Peyton manning is still bitching about it after the Superbowl or say,
and they make a fucking tape and they send it to the league and the league goes
to Patriots did nothing wrong.
That is legal.
Jim Irsay sat on the rules committee and the very next year,
the way the Patriots were covering the fucking colts was now suddenly illegal.
And after five yards you couldn't touch him and you just had to escort him down
the field.
And they had Peyton manning in his prime.
Well guess what?
The colts beat the Patriots and then they won a super bowl.
Is that cheating?
Is that gamesmanship?
And as far as the spy gate thing goes,
there was a league wide memo telling everybody to stop doing it.
Yeah.
Okay.
The stop having a fucking camera man standing down there on the sidelines in
front of all the fans.
They told everybody to stop doing it.
Eric Mann,
genie fucking built his resume doing that shit.
Oh Jesus.
Somebody just rang the door.
Am I going to get in trouble here?
What happens?
She'll give me a fucking break.
So the Patriots get caught and then all of a sudden they question their entire
fucking,
uh,
legacy.
Okay.
Oh,
and then meanwhile we go off and win like fucking 13 games every God damn year
for the rest of the fucking time.
And then people like,
well,
you didn't win a Superbowl.
And it's like,
oh yeah,
that has nothing to do with our defense.
It has to do with the fact that we weren't fucking filming people can be a God
damn break because I'll tell you this right now,
if just filming the other team got you a god Damn Dynasty,
every fucking team in the league would still be doing it and they'd be just
doing it right up from the coach's box.
There's no camera with the zoom on it.
And if you think people aren't fucking doing that now,
stealing goddamned signs.
Absolutely they are.
Hang on a second.
There's somebody here.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hello.
Oh,
hey.
Room service.
All right.
Set it down like that with the title.
You just put it right down on the table right here.
Right here.
This table.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
I'm sorry about that.
There you go.
You liked that.
That was actual room service captured on a podcast.
Um,
so whatever,
all you guys out there,
all you patriots haters,
you can run out of you.
You guys can run your miles all you want.
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
Your team's doing shit too.
I love how only we get questioned about that stuff.
The saints were taken out,
bounties on other players.
Does anybody questioned their super bowl title?
I don't.
You know,
did you guys see Fran Tarkington losing his mind?
He's still talking about Superbowl nine when he showed up and he talked to his
linemen.
Was it stu void as that?
What's the guy's name?
It's like a hall of Famer and he's looking over at the Steelers and he's looking
at looking at the vikings and he just goes,
how come it's so much bigger than we are?
It turns out later,
like 90% of them were on Roids,
including Terry Bradshaw who admitted that he was on roids.
Does anybody
questioned the fucking super Steelers or the seventies no.
So go fuck yourself if you're going to be sitting here talking about Goddam
balls that weighed like fucking half a fucking whatever the fuck it was that
minute.
Unbelievable deflate gate.
And by the way,
can we stop putting gate at the end of everything?
That was funny in like the 1980s with the Iran Contra and somebody called it a
Ron gate.
And ever since then everything is gate.
It's just like fucking hacks come up with a better God damn joke.
So there you go,
everybody.
All you fucking country.
We were on Twitter and you're trying to say that.
Uh,
okay.
You know the Patriots have bunch of cheaters.
I see through everything he is saying.
You're saying you're sick of losing to us,
but get used to it because Tom Brady still has another three,
four years left.
Now can we get on to talk to talking about the Super Bowl?
Okay.
She's arguably the greatest fucking matchup gone.
Oh,
you know what made a fucking great point about the Patriots?
Colts think,
um,
okay.
I did another fucking stain on the God damn table.
Sorry man.
I gotta clean this fucking table.
Got Dan was so fucking gross fucking rose.
Anyways,
it's going to be a great guy damn game.
Um,
I still,
Seattle should be favored,
but every mouse breeding moron in Vegas is going to see Brady and Bella check.
So they put their money over there.
So then Vegas has got to adjust the line to get money on both sides of the ball.
It's the same old fucking story.
But um,
I actually liked it.
This whole stupid deflated footballs things came out.
Um,
I think that's going to work to our advantage.
MMM.
Nah.
Maybe if we played this Sunday,
I think by next Sunday it's going to be pretty much fucking over.
MMM.
I'll be looking for some silly stupid signs from dumb fans all painted in green.
You know,
the Seattle fans will have signs talking about the Patriots,
like the cheaters and a knit.
No point will it dawn on them.
Why they don't sound even remotely is loud in a different stadium.
They'll blame it on the fact that half the place is filled with fucking patriots
fans.
Well,
do the math.
He should at least be half as loud as you are on your stadium,
which you're not going to be,
because down there in Arizona,
it's just a regular old stadium.
So there you go.
That's my whole take on that type of thing.
And,
uh,
here's the deal.
If we play the fucking Superbowl in Seattle,
beats us and they do some dumb shit,
like fucking the flight the ball a little bit,
you know,
and we lose by 38.
Okay.
Give me a fucking break.
I will sit there and be like,
wow,
the Seattle Seahawks just kicked her fucking ass.
That's what I would say.
But you know,
that's not how the fucking world works,
isn't it?
When you get fucking for 24 hours,
mmm.
24 hour,
uh,
sports channels,
it's a fucking lead story on CNN.
Yeah.
Give me a fucking break.
So
anyways,
what,
what do I think about the Superbowl?
I have no,
I mean,
I think on paper the fucking sea hawks win.
I think defense wins championships as they always say,
and they have the better defense and a monster defense.
Um,
I love that defense.
I think,
uh,
okay.
And I think it's way easier to shut down to patriots' offense than it is to beat
Seattle's defense.
And I think our defenses is good,
but it's not as good as Seattle's and what I look at it.
I just feel like that's going to be the difference.
Um,
we're not good at stopping the run and they have Marshawn lynch and a Russell
Wilson as obviously looking pretty human after the last game,
but I mean,
maybe just had a bad game,
but,
uh,
that guy's mobile is hell.
And so we're always seeking as all teams,
we're going to have to have one guy just sitting there babysitting him the
entire fucking game.
But,
uh,
they don't have the greatest receivers.
I Dunno,
but I still,
you know,
if we can't get any pressure on the quarterback,
yeah.
I swear to God.
So I don't know.
Uh,
I just think on paper we lose,
but for some reason I have a good feeling.
For some reason I think we're gonna win.
That's probably just me as a patriots fan,
but,
uh,
this is really a Superbowl.
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
I have no idea about,
but I got this feeling that it's going to be a classic.
I really hope it is.
Um,
I don't want to see a boring one,
but here's the thing.
I don't know if I'm even going to be able to see it live.
I think I'll be live.
We'll do it live.
I think I'm actually flying to New Zealand when the fucking game is on and it's
a five hour flight.
They better have some fucking TVs on there,
man.
I screwed up book in this tape.
This fucking,
yeah.
Toro when I did,
how the fuck did I know the paths were going to be in this God damn Superbowl.
Okay.
Remember that when they lost to the fucking chiefs,
now everybody's acting like they didn't fucking say that they were done.
I was convinced they were done.
I thought,
uh,
you know,
I just felt like it,
we just kept getting rid of veterans didn't want to pay their last contract and
we just were getting slowly weaker by the season.
I totally bought into it.
So I'm a surprises anybody that were there.
So that's it.
I won't talk anymore about that shit.
So anyways,
I'm over here in Australia and uh,
today Lo and behold is a Australia day.
I don't know why.
I don't know what it is.
If it's their independent day,
I don't know that,
you know,
I don't know a fucking thing about Australia.
I know they have a very similar,
um,
history to the United States in that,
you know,
they had some English come over here,
right?
And then there was people already here.
So that was a problem.
And they dealt with it in a,
that,
uh,
centuries later,
you know,
musicians and shit with guilt would write songs.
She didn't,
they out where the ribs are broke,
right.
The time has come.
You remember that guy?
He said the time has come to save fair's fair to pay the rent to pair a pair
share and then the any,
let's give it back.
Wham,
wham.
Wound
give what back the fucking land and then what you get,
you going to displace fucking 9 million people.
I mean,
fucking people in this country.
Yeah.
Silver.
You know,
it's a terrible thing that happened.
Just give him casinos like we did and you get on with your lives.
So anyways,
I have no idea what Australia Day is.
Um,
I could probably look it up here for you if you want to.
You already heard from service,
you want to listen to me fucking type here anyways.
It's say basically they celebrate Australia.
Okay.
I kind kinda think that they could've come up with a better fucking name in
Australia Day.
Yeah.
Hey,
it's USA day.
Yeah.
It's not attached to anything but whatever.
I got to respect that everybody gets a day off,
which is great.
And on a Monday,
which is even better.
So you get a three day fucking weekend and then everybody kind of boozes it up.
We've got out here to pursue,
you know what I saw too fucking El Camino looking cars that I haven't seen like
a,
yeah,
I don't like,
I don't,
it wasn't made by Chevrolet,
but what was fucking hilarious is that both people were fucking kind of doing
burnouts and driving like assholes.
So it's nice to see that,
that that made me feel like I was home.
Oh.
Like a guy with a ratty haircut driving a fucking El Camino looking car.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Uh,
Australia Day is the official official,
the official national day.
So that's how I read my fucking brain is ahead of my goddamn mouth.
Australia Day,
Australia Day is he official national day of Australia,
yet a celebrated annually on the 26th of January.
It marks the anniversary of the 1788 arrival of the first fleet of British ships
at Porch Action,
New South Wales and raising of the flag,
the flag of Great Britain at that site by Governor Arthur Phillip.
By the way,
that reference,
do you have a flag that's um,
Eddie Izzard who was actually on my flight.
Um,
and I want to say a lot of them cause I'm a huge fan,
but I don't know,
I just felt like I was going to be bugging him so I didn't,
he's actually over here right now.
Thank God not playing the same city that I'm playing or I wouldn't have sold any
tickets.
I'm in present day Australia celebrations reflect a diverse society and
landscape of the nation.
Nice.
See how they wiggled their way out of that.
Cause I was just saying the indigenous people here,
it must not be thinking January 26 was the great fucking day in their history.
So now they've kind of moved it around.
It's kind of a,
you know,
the diverse society that we live in.
You know,
we live in doors and,
uh,
you live outdoors in the a outback,
or maybe you sit around playing a fucking Didgeridoo on the street corner in
Sydney.
Um,
family events,
reflections on Australian history,
reflections on Australian history.
Hey,
you probably shouldn't have killed all those people.
Uh,
officially official community.
And I'm not judging you guys.
You Ozzie people.
Okay?
We get the same fucking history and worse.
Imagine if you did that and then you added slavery,
and then,
uh,
then you let a select group of people take over your food supply and turn it
into poison,
right?
And then everybody gets addicted.
And then years later you yell at the fat people on a show called the biggest
loser.
You know what?
They finally came out with the fucking article talking about how dangerous that
show is.
Uh,
me and Nia used to watch that all the time.
And I used to sit there saying,
they're going to fucking kill somebody.
Somebody is going to die.
I don't work out this hard ever in my fucking life.
And,
uh,
you know,
I'm not 400 pounds over fucking weight,
but they were talking,
they did this whole article on it,
talking about people fucking up their joints and having a really,
really bad problems and afterwards and putting the weight back on and the diets
that basically,
the amount of calories that they give them is like really dangerous and all this
shit that you obviously knew when you watch the fucking show.
But um,
okay.
Uh,
one of the funniest things was,
uh,
something,
I can't even fucking remember.
What the fuck was I just thinking of Jesus Christ.
I mean,
this is the usual me out of my mind and I'm beyond fucking jetlagged.
Um,
yeah.
Oh,
I know they said like really over the top main stuff.
Like you're not going to see your daughter's 12th birthday and is mean is that
is it's actually true though.
You can't walk around some of this shit they were doing.
There was one guy,
I was actually jealous of him,
you know,
not that he was fat,
but just the fact I would love to have done what he did every day.
He fucking had like three quarter pounders with cheese and like three large
fries for lunch and a giant coke.
You know,
I know that you would feel like shit afterwards,
but just think of how awesome that would be as you are consuming it.
When you felt that rush of salt and sugar,
just sending your mood and everything else
through the fucking roof.
That's one of those things where you just start rocking back and forth.
By the time you get into the third one,
you've already drinking half a gallon of soda.
He started like humming songs that didn't even exist before.
You know,
it's a very creative point during that process before you just completely crash
out.
Um,
but anyways,
whatever,
how many minutes a week in here?
Oh Shit.
32 minutes.
Okay.
Let me,
let me a little bit of advertising.
What was getting,
no,
let me attempt.
Let me attempt to read here.
You know what the time has come to read the fucking advertisement.
Okay?
Why the hell is it live reads all right.
Bam.
Okay.
90% Oh,
Mandy's me undies.
No more sweaty balls.
Bodu boo boo.
Hey,
you know what?
I'm actually wearing a pair right now and I gotta tell you they even work down
under,
down under my fucking balls.
Down under your under carriage.
All right,
90%.
That's the percentage.
90% that's the percent of your life that you're going to be in your underwear
and the underwear.
It gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on old saggy underwear,
that does stink.
Right.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I was just fucking hanging down like MC hammer pants.
He balls and just hang in there,
right?
Yeah.
Just fucking hanging like a Jesus Christ my underwear quick.
Why should I even try today?
Then you walk in.
Yeah,
your boss goes,
yeah,
listen.
Uh,
we did a review.
You're not getting a raise and he just still had,
it's all right.
Your head hangs down just like your boss,
just like your underwear.
It all goes south,
just like you life.
Then your wife or your fucking girlfriend leaves you or your boyfriend,
whatever you fucking deal is.
And you know,
it's just,
it's not a good thing.
All right?
So what you need to do is you need to know about me undies.com B and e's is the
most comfortable underwear you will ever wear.
And it's insane how good they make you feel.
Yeah.
And by they,
they may need your bowls.
They fit perfectly right.
They don't ride up on you and they literally pull moisture away from your skin
grows.
So you stay cool.
I have mine on right now and I am floating.
Well,
I got mine on right now.
I wouldn't say I'm floating up fucking chilling though.
Uh,
they have cool styles for both men and women.
They all look great.
Oh,
for women to me undies,
me undies,
no more.
Claimy clam,
no more yeast infections.
Boom.
Ba,
Ba da Ba da Ba da Ba da Ba.
Keep it off your fucking clam.
Get that moisture gone.
Oh yeah.
Nobody wants a sweaty clam.
All right.
Check out the photos yourself of what?
Sweaty clams.
Oh,
at [inaudible] dot com this quality with typically retail for two times to me,
Andy price according to me undies.
I don't know if you guys are up on the fucking price underwear.
No.
Retail middlemen means more savings for you here.
I'll make it easy.
Go to me and he's dot com slash bar and get 20% off your first order and free
shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy with them or your first pair is free.
That's funny.
They bring guarantee they're going to be happier.
First pairs for you.
I'm not happy.
Not happy with it.
Yeah,
we got it for free.
Well,
it doesn't mean I'm going to wear can you take them back?
I don't need the clutter.
All right.
Academy of Sports Medicine,
they are here.
New Year's resolutions.
Oh my God.
Everyone's got Wong.
Get in Shay,
be healthier or get a new job.
Stop hating myself.
A become a certified personal trainer with the National Academy of Sports
Medicine and you can do all three.
You know what better time to become a personal trainer when our food supply has
been turned into poison.
Uh,
the fitness industry is booming and the demand for personal trainers is soaring.
Imagine waking up every day excited to get to work,
uh,
not,
not to a job,
but to a rewarding career.
It is.
She can help somebody stopped their food addiction and not die by the time their
kid is 12.
That's about as rewarding as it get when you think,
uh,
getting paid to stay in shape while helping others to reach their fitness goals.
You set your own hours,
work in health clubs,
sports clinics and corporates,
corporate wellness,
and you'll love who you work with.
Yeah.
And then eventually you take your clients and you start working out in your own
garage.
That's what you do.
You build your own fucking gym in the garage and that way you don't have to pay
any commission to the gym and you get your clients over there,
you start a revolutionary workout,
right?
Then you write a book and then you make a million.
Then you get,
then you,
then you're on your way,
right?
Get out of your cubicles,
work for yourself.
Okay.
Finally,
do what you truly enjoy and get paid for it.
Get a headstart on 2015 and begin your certification from the National Academy
of Sports Medicine.
Now,
if you don't land a job as a personal trainer within 60 days assertive
certification,
they'll give you your money back guaranteed.
Uh,
go to my USA trainer.com for free.
14 day sneak peek of their fast and fun online program.
That's my USA trainer.com.
My US trainer.com restrictions apply.
Visit my USA trainer.com for details.
That's pretty cool,
man.
I could be a personal trainer.
I mean,
I couldn't,
the way I'm shaped right now,
but I mean like I could do that fucking job,
I think.
Yeah,
I don't be a fun job and then you would stay in shape because you know,
no one's going to go to a fat personal trainer.
It'd be good.
A good motivation.
All right,
vegas.com unless you get some pussy.
Did you see that?
That fucking dude in the Kayak that tipped over.
Hello
me.
I don't know what,
Ooh,
you got to see this thing if I can find it.
Okay.
Some woman taped her fucking friend waters
filling up in the Chi egg.
If I move it
to you,
this is an adult get imagined trying to personal train that person.
I can't imagine the amount of women out there that are personal trainers,
right?
To some fucking Schlubby guy who fucking bitches and moans that that's got to be
extra fucking awful for him.
You know,
just to sit there and dealing with,
I already,
if he got some whiny female client,
I would think of whiny dude would be even worse.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Anyways,
let me just move on here.
vegas.com everybody.
10% off everything excluding air hotel packages using my code,
Burr B,
U R,
r a vegas.com is the way to book Vegas.
All right?
They really do serve up Vegas from the inside because unlike the other travel
sites,
they're from Vegas.
They live in Vegas,
work in Vegas,
party in Vegas.
They give you insider tips on where to stay and what to do when you get there.
vegas.com coms propriety drop watch tool promises the lowest rates on hotels.
Drop Watch continues to monitor the prices even after you book and notifies you
of changes to ensure that you get the best deal book at the lower rate and they
will refund you the difference.
Um,
what book at the lower rate and they will refund you the difference.
What do you mean?
I'm poking at the lower rate.
The difference of what?
The higher price I was paying.
Oh,
Jesus.
Uh,
vegas.com saves you money on shows.
Headliners shows comedy,
Penn and Teller Ron White carrot tops,
Cirque de Solei,
vegas.com offers more VIP bottle service at top clubs.
Oh,
we're in the fold.
The vap will movie cheap tickets.
Best Strip clubs go to vegas.com right now.
And when you book hotels,
shows,
clubs,
pick anything on the site that suits you.
Enter my code burr in the promo box and check out a check at checkout and get an
extra 10% off everything but air,
hotel packages.
That's vegas.com get bonus savings with my secret code.
B.
U.
R.
I got to tell you guys,
if he wants some insider thing,
they kind of alluded to it.
Now they're getting away from it.
But um,
you can go out to Vegas and you can drive like a fucking Lamborghini or a
Ferrari on a race track.
If you get off the strip,
you also go out there and you can shoot a fucking machine gun in the desert.
Okay?
Anybody can go and get some fake boobs rubbed in their fucking face.
Okay.
Is he drink a drink with the fucking umbrella in it?
You know,
I'm not saying don't do that.
All right.
Definitely do that and have a good time.
But you know,
he should also be talking to her,
you know,
a Porsche.
You always showing up.
She ain't gone today while Rhonda in a Ferrari.
You could do something like that.
Um,
all right.
I apologize for that awful fucking,
just awful.
Everything in general,
the content,
where the hell is it?
Come on man.
Come back to me.
It's time for the content and you won't show it to me.
All right,
here we go.
Wait,
was there anything else I want to talk about before I got into the emails before
I got real light,
before I got into the emails?
Uh,
Oh,
you know what I,
when I was on the plane ride over,
um,
I,
uh,
you know,
I,
I watched that movie Lucy,
that was a movie that I wanted to see in,
um,
and the theaters.
It just kind of came and went and I didn't hear the greatest things about it.
I got to tell you for a rental,
it's,
it's not bad.
It's not a bad movie.
You know,
you got that,
that big pouty lips,
a Hardy's,
you know,
she's running around whatever fucking name is
Sebastian Bach.
What the fuck is her name?
She's got one of those names.
Set the chick.
It's like the CIC version of Sebastian Bach.
Right?
What is her name?
Aniston.
It's a really beautiful now.
Anyway,
she's in it and uh,
uh,
they got some good bad guys.
They got like some Asian mob guys.
Those guys are always call,
you know what I mean?
I fucking cut their finger off if they do something bad for their boss.
I've always liked that.
I've always liked the,
uh,
the Italian mob thing.
I've always liked that.
And,
uh,
the Asian mob guys,
you know what I mean?
Cause the Asian mob guys always combine like fucking,
not only can they shoot a gun,
but then they always added the martial arts shit in there with fucking knives
and spin this stuff around.
You know,
that's what I like about the Asian mob before they whack you.
They have the decency to put on like a show,
like,
like murder,
Cirque de Solei,
right?
Torture,
Cirque,
Cirque de Solei,
whatever the fuck it is.
I actually watched that.
And then,
you know,
I still had another like five hours on the flight.
And,
um,
I listened to a sergeant peppers,
the whole fucking album,
which I hadn't listened to and so long.
That is one of the greatest fucking albums of all time.
And this is kind of this backlash by younger people.
They tried to say the Beatles are overrated.
Um,
and all I'm gonna say is,
I just feel bad for you guys because I had never heard j Dilla until he died.
And I follow Questlove on Twitter and he did some sort of link and I kinda got
into that guy.
And if you actually listen to the sergeant pepper with all the shift that they
got going on in the background,
crowd noises and all that,
and he's crazy sounds and all of that,
you almost see like the,
these elements of what j Dilla was doing on that album like fucking 40 years
before.
It's absolutely fucking amazing album.
But anyways,
so we were flying,
right?
And as always,
I use all my miles when I,
I got a really long flight like this.
And uh,
so we were riding up front like big shots and this woman was up front.
These two women were sitting next to each other and in front of them they had
two little kids.
And then there was another little kid and these kids would run an all all the
fuck way around.
And,
um,
is there anything worse than seeing a parent whose kid just doesn't even listen
to them?
It's like seeing a coach that like lost the locker room.
The kid can't get in up.
The kid was getting up.
We was still taking off.
Like we were still,
we were still ascending to our cruising altitude and,
um,
this,
she'd be like,
she'd go,
Hey,
I told you to sit down.
And he would just look at her,
nod her head,
and they continue to fucking run around.
And um,
I dunno,
she looked over me at one point.
I just gave her this fucking look like,
uh,
I dunno what it was.
I was annoyed
okay.
As a kid kept,
you know,
running by and that bumping into you and the kid was old enough to not be cute
anymore.
You know,
it was just old enough where I was considering tripping him when he went by.
He was like,
Dad,
age,
what does that age like six,
seven years old,
not seven,
seven.
He can talk to them.
It's like,
look,
foreign entity,
you don't lay your hands on them between four and six,
you trip.
Um,
and then after that age,
you just look at him like you sit them down like a person you like,
dude,
what the fuck's wrong with you?
All right.
Is that good parenting?
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
all right,
let's get to the fucking questions here for the week.
What the hell are they?
Okay,
I'll tell you.
It's cool being at the airport,
man,
now that I'm actually flying and all this shit that I looked out the window and
I never fucking understood.
I'm actually seeing what runway we're on,
what taxi way we're on and I'm figuring out why we're still holding their,
you know,
it was pretty fucking cool cause it was a horrible weather,
just gloomy and that type of shit.
So,
um,
the fucking,
the,
a tower had like all this traffic lined up and we were just sitting there and my
wife's going like,
you know,
how come,
why not leave?
And when I leave and I'm looking out the window and I think I was able to call
it like when,
when he was going to let us go.
Um,
okay.
I don't know.
I can't wait to get back to that.
I got six more lessons and then I actually take my,
I had my check ride and a,
I can't fucking wait.
I can't fuck it.
I'll be a major fucking accomplishment if I actually get that thing.
I gotta be honest with you.
I brought my notebooks and all that shit to study and I'm just fucking pretests
on the Internet and uh,
I dunno,
you got to get a 70% and my school tries to get you up to like 90.
And um,
I,
I'm all over the map.
I'm 85 90 on some shit and other stuff.
I'm in the 60s,
but I'm no lower than the 60.
So I figured out this the next three weeks as I'm out on the road,
I'll just try to do an hour and a half every fucking day.
Um,
anyway,
so probably bored the shit out of you,
but I don't care.
All right.
Be The match.
Everybody,
uh,
Billy MD,
I'm a 45 year old female whose son survived from a rare form of bone marrow
cancer because of be the match.org.
Uh,
be the match.org was something that I,
I,
uh,
mentioned joining,
um,
a couple podcasts ago,
case you weren't listening.
So anyways,
I was driving to work and listening to your podcast and when you mentioned this,
I almost started screaming for joy.
Uh,
we near the first who ever listened to my podcast who considered screaming for
joy unless I was saying,
well,
that's the podcast for this week.
Then they usually like,
oh,
thank God it's over.
Um,
we were told that he would have a very hard time qualifying to be a donor.
Okay.
Because of certain factors.
You mean getting a donor?
Um,
very hard time.
Yeah.
To be a donor,
I think.
You mean qualify getting a call,
a match,
I should say.
Anyways,
we stayed positive and after a year and a half,
a donor match was found.
The match was a young man in his late twenties who had heard about be the match
and decided to enter,
uh,
decided to register on a whim.
Thank you so much for mentioning it on the podcast.
My husband and I often question why programs like this aren't mentioned in
bigger forums,
uh,
be at 60 minutes or the state of the Union address.
I don't know anyone who wouldn't help someone save someone's life if they could
the donor or as we refer to him as superman had heard about this from a friend
at a dinner party,
attending that dinner party in turn saved my son's life,
which means that you can be part of saving someone's life to just by having
mentioned it,
uh,
I'm welling up just writing this email and I know your listeners are usually
writing in about psycho women and sports,
but if you happen,
if you do happen to read this,
I just want you to know that it means the world to watch.
He says this too fucking nice for me to read.
Um,
too many competencies to reiterate what you mentioned on the podcast.
The test is literally just swapping,
I think swabbing your cheek with a Qtip,
not swapping it cheek.
That would be a,
some face off shit.
Uh,
with the Qtip they send you and putting it in a mailbox.
If you happen to match with someone in the registry,
they contact you and you have the option of saving someone's life.
Fuck this.
I'm doing this.
I gotta do that.
Jesus Christ,
uh,
be the match.org.
Everybody.
How about you do that?
Why don't you guys go out and do that thing and then the next time you spouse,
your girlfriend or your boyfriend gives you shit.
Like,
what are you been doing all day?
What have I been doing?
Save and fucking lives.
Lady or Buddy live women say to they guys,
you fucking asshole.
All right.
Got Drunk.
Said some things.
Wow.
Got Drunk.
Said some things that I write this a dear bill.
I am what many people have called a habitual line crosser.
Ah,
the classic Charlie Murphy Line from the Rick James Sketch.
Uh,
I am a habitual line crosser.
When I drank last night,
I was out with some coworkers and my boss.
Oh No,
at a brewery festival.
Oh,
geesh.
All right.
What do you guys guessing here?
Um,
probably told his boss he didn't know what he was doing and if his boss was
female,
he probably made a pass at her.
What do you guys go going with?
Did he say something dumb or did he grab somebody's ass?
Anyways,
I ended up getting,
fuck,
I ended up getting fucking rocked.
It told my boss to her face.
Oh my God,
she's a female.
Here we go.
I am willing to lose my job to sleep with you.
That's actually kind of funny.
He said she laughed and blushed at the bold statement and proceeded to leave
almost directly after this.
Oh,
now,
oh,
you set it to the wrong person.
Uh,
you said it to the wrong person.
I'm writing this to you on Sunday morning and have to report to the old fucking
clock puncher tomorrow.
I have no shame addressing sexual tension with the woman,
but my boss,
fuck me.
My plan is to just carry on like it never happened because honestly I don't care
and see how she responds with either a not addressing it and keeping me
employed,
be filing sexual harassment,
losing my job and sleeping with me.
And he writes,
yeah.
C Filing,
sexual harassment,
losing my job and not sleeping with me,
Bu uh,
letting me keep my job and sleeping with me.
Fuck yeah.
What's your,
what's your take on all of this?
Um,
I don't have a take on it cause you have to give a shit.
Yeah.
And you don't,
you're one of those guys.
I have no problem.
I have no shame addressing sexual tension.
Um,
I love the sexual tension.
What your sexual attention.
It doesn't seem like she had any,
you kind of just looking at this from your own perspective.
Um,
you have all the makings of a high ranking CEO of a corporation because you,
you don't give a shit.
You have no guilt whatsoever.
You've already weighed out all the options.
He say that I get away with it a,
the dewar I don't,
you've completely emotionally not even attached to this thing.
Um,
you're a dangerous human being.
I hope you don't get,
uh,
I hope you're not in charge of the fucking water supply.
All right.
Relationship Advice.
Yo Billy Bitch tits.
First off,
just want to say any right now.
That guy's like,
what the fuck,
man,
that's fucking dude.
Think about it right now.
You don't have any guilt whatsoever.
You don't give a fuck.
You're not looking like,
aw man,
I got a drinking problem.
I uh,
you know I got to change my life.
You know,
if I'm going to get anywhere in life,
if you completely don't even give a shit and then you turn yourself into like
this fucking hero,
I got no problem addressing sexual attention.
Hey,
you know who I am.
You know I am.
So he's got to say it's going to be mate,
Eh,
whatever
man.
Good for you.
I hope your banger.
Alright,
it's time for some more advertising.
I actually forgot to read these things,
so,
uh,
just had to fucking read these and then drop them in.
So sorry for the abrupt,
um,
going from the badlands and talking about the fucking advertising.
All right,
here we go.
DSC everybody.
Delta,
Sierra,
Charlie,
uh,
can someone tell me when raisers,
oh,
that's dollar shave club.
Now they're DSC.
These guys are feeling themselves.
Uh,
can someone please tell me when races gets so damn expensive?
Have I been asleep for the last 20 years?
I was in a store one day and one of the packs of razors cost 20 bucks and it's
only one pack people.
That's absolutely nuts.
All right.
But you know,
sometimes they actually give you a free deck,
a free deck of freak,
a free gift when you buy their overprice raises,
which is actually just a punched in the Dick.
Dude,
I swear to God I cannot fucking read.
And then I try and riff and then I'm thinking like,
just get to the dick part.
That's the joke.
Give you a free deck.
They give you a free deck.
Everybody,
here you go bad.
Souray Yardi got one.
Now you got an extra one.
You never know.
All right?
Don't get beat up by ridiculous.
Raise their prices.
Get your shape gear where I get mine from,
dollar Shave club.com for just a few bucks to all the shave club.com delivers
amazing razors and other great grooming supplies right to your doorstep.
Like Dr Carver's,
easy shave potter.
Um,
their plan starts at just $3 and here's how it works.
They send me the handle for free and every month they send me replacement
blades.
It's one less thing to worry about.
You can get deliveries every month or every other month.
However the hell you want to do it.
They got lots of other grooming supplies too.
You know that.
I love the one wipe Charlies.
Why pay $20 for a razor when you can get a fantastic shave from dollar shave
club.com for a fraction of the price stop getting smacked around by high res of
prices.
You son of a bitch,
dollar shave club.com raises are great and they're a fraction of the price.
Trust me,
you'll wish that you had done this sooner.
Don't be a dumb ass.
Shave smarter.
Go to dollar shave club.com/bar that's dollar shave club.com/bar dollar shave
club.com/burr.
All right.
stamps.com everybody,
the classic trips to the post office are never convenient,
so why not get postage right from your desk with stamps.com stamps.com even
gives you special postage discounts that you cannot get at the post office,
including FirstClass priority mail express international in more.
You'll never pay full price for postage.
Again.
Here's how stamps.com works.
Using your own computer and printer.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter or package than just hand your
mail to the mailman or drop it in the mailbox.
Bing,
Bang,
boom.
That's that easy you'd done.
It's no wonder over 500,000 small businesses are already using stamps.com I use
stamps.com to send out all my posters whenever I'm whoring myself out after
shows trying to make a bit of extra cash.
I'm a moron if I could figure out,
so can you right now I use my last name [inaudible] to get this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible].
And lastly,
but not leastly legal zone.
What's your top New Year's resolution?
If you're like me,
it's getting your life organized.
Um,
but where do you begin?
A great place to start is protecting your family and a great way to take control
of your family's future is making a will or living trust.
That's where legal zoom can help.
There's no easier way to make sure your family is legally taken care of.
Getting your life organized also means taking control of your financial affairs.
So if you're thinking of starting a business or you're or you already have one,
legal zoom can help,
can help you form your business,
what can help you form your business and provide the support you need to run it
successfully for more than 10 years.
Legal Zoom has helped millions of people get personalized attention that they
need.
And if you'd like more help,
they can connect you with an independent attorney in most states,
but they are not a law of farm for this month.
You can save even more by entering burr in the referral box at checkout.
That Promo Code is bird.
Don't let another year passed before getting your life organized for legal help.
You can count on your family or small business.
Go to legalzoom.com Promo Code [inaudible] B u.
R.
R a relationship advice.
Yo,
belly bitch tits.
First off,
just want to say huge fan of your standup podcast.
Okay.
All right,
so I am 21 years old and in the military living in England,
I just got here two months ago and have a girlfriend back home in the states who
I've been with for about a year and a half.
And you've already met someone who wants to bang you over there cause you got an
accent and a military haircut and you've been doing pull ups and you're in the
prime of your life,
right?
That's what I'm guessing.
She's a great girl.
Tall Brunette has a fucking rock and body.
Hell Jesus.
And this is sweetheart with a good family.
A good Lord Dude.
If all of that is true,
I would rub one out in England for a while.
Um,
I feel like I hit the Jackpot and we are working on getting her over here.
Uh,
which would mean we would have to be married.
I want to do it,
but at the same time,
whenever we talk about it,
I get nervous as fuck and this weird feeling in my gut holding me back.
I don't know if that's normal cold feet or what.
I feel like if I dumped her,
have you making a huge mistake,
but at the same time I don't want to get married and wake up two years from now.
Angry that I wasn't single living overseas and could have had the time of my
life.
What would you do in my situation?
She's the mother of my kids
material.
What
but not sure if we're too young.
Oh,
she's the mother of my kids material,
but not sure if we're too young.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
I don't know how old you,
I sound like a young,
I would address this with her.
Okay.
I don't know.
Is that bad advice?
I think every guy fucking has cold feet freaks the fuck out.
Okay.
And it's just like Jesus Christ,
what the fuck am I doing?
What the fuck am I doing?
Cause women get married.
It's just like,
there's such an advantage to it.
You know,
the way the divorce laws are set up,
like they're there for the most part,
they're not going to lose unless they're making more money and then they gotta
be nervous,
I would think.
Yeah.
But also,
I think just in general,
they're there.
They believe in that romance stuff and all that Shit.
What would you do?
I don't know,
man.
That's a fucking rough one.
And all of a sudden it's a rough one,
you know?
Do you love her?
You know what I mean?
If you love her and you don't want to lose her,
I got to tell you.
Um,
yeah,
you won't regret marrying her.
Yeah.
Alright.
Occasionally you'll be pissed that you didn't crush all that ass over there and
you're going to the bathroom and you'll rub one out and the second year rub one
out.
You gotta be like,
Ah,
you know I made the right fucking choice.
All right.
I Dunno.
You 21 years old or do you,
you're not going to get married at 21.
Here's the deal.
Just tell you want to be with her.
Be Not ready to get married.
You're only 21 years old.
That's what I would do.
See,
I don't want to be married yet.
I'm only 21 I want to experience my twenties a little bit.
What do you mean fuck somebody else?
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
Dude,
you're only 21 years old.
Okay.
If just fucking woman Ari wants to get married,
I mean,
I think it's normal to 21 to fucking not want to get married.
Just say,
look,
let's get married around like 26 what is the rush?
Let's be single and fucking enjoy ourselves,
but like be together,
whatever.
I would go down that road.
Um,
oh Jesus,
you're not.
Sometimes you guys ask me these life changing fucking questions and I got to try
to weigh all options here.
I don't want you to get rid of the love of your life.
And I also don't want to fucking have you locked down at 21.
It's going to come down to use their fucking private.
You're going to have to figure this one out.
MMM.
But uh,
yeah,
I would,
I would start with that.
See if he can,
oh,
I see.
To get her over there.
You'd have to fucking marry her to,
that's not a reason to merrier.
I would do the long distance relationship thing.
Um,
I don't know what the fuck I would do.
All right.
Sorry.
I did my best.
If anybody has any advice for this kid,
just fucking write in next week and I'll,
you know,
if that makes sense.
I'll read it.
All right.
And knowing father-in-law,
dear bill,
I'm a pretty well rounded guy.
All right.
Fucking right out of the gates.
Guy's patting himself on the back.
I'm not a complete stiff,
but I'm also not a flake.
Wait a minute,
dude.
Those are both bad things.
You know,
I'm not a jerk,
but I'm also not an asshole.
I'm not a complete stiff.
We're also not a flake.
Ah,
well that doesn't make any fucking sense.
Anyways,
I have my shit in order.
When you work hard to have your life together,
the last thing you want is someone telling you stuff you don't need to hear
about when you supposed to be doing
or what you're supposed to be doing with your life and money.
Okay.
My father in law is this person in my life.
All he cares about is the market,
stocks,
bonds,
mutual funds,
Iras.
He actually wrote box instead of bonds.
All he talks about is watching his money grow and how I should be saving
everything so I can live rich when I'm older.
The thing is I do save aggressively.
I'm doing just fine.
Recently I booked a trip to Greece to surprise my wife for our third wedding
anniversary on our first date.
She said she always wanted to go to Greece.
I told her she get there within five years.
That was just under five years ago though.
Hey,
you're the man of your word.
It seems like I can't claim through clutch here.
Her father on the other hand said it was not the right time because of the
exchange rate,
safety of traveling abroad and anything else he could throw in there.
How do I respond to him?
Do I laugh it off and just wait till he talks shit again and again and live with
it.
Who would I put him,
pull him aside and let them know I don't want to hear this his shit anymore.
Thanks.
I would do both.
I would experimenting with laughing it off.
Yeah,
at first.
And if he keeps coming at you at some point you just got to take them aside,
you know,
and just be like,
listen,
um,
I would actually talk to you,
my uh,
your wife about it first just to tell her that you're going to do it just in
case he comes at her with his fucking story of like,
I was just trying to help it.
I think he just brow beaten me.
I would just say he just said to your wife like,
listen,
I know your father means well,
but,
uh,
you know,
he's always talking to me about my finances,
our finances and that type of thing.
All right.
I know he's very smart with money and that type of thing,
but I also feel like I'm smart with money in my own way.
All right.
And,
uh,
I've saved my money and we can afford this and where young and you're beautiful
and you want to go to Greece and I'm taking it because I love you.
All right?
But I gotta be honest with you,
if your dad keeps opening is Yep.
I'm going to fucking shove a dinner roll in it.
Are we cool?
All right.
What are we watching tonight?
Real housewives.
Are we going to watch the little sports?
Whose night is it?
There you go.
And then you were up,
but at some point,
yeah,
you got to sit down.
If you do have
an,
uh,
an annoying person like that in your life,
you really do.
You got to sit down with them and you have to do it.
Uh,
I do it in our restaurant.
Take them out to lunch,
you know,
so there's no option for any screaming and yelling and I'm just lay it on the
light.
You just got to say to them that,
listen,
you know,
I love your daughter more than anything in the world and you have to know that
I'm going to take care of her.
All right?
And then it'll be all right,
right off the bat.
You catch them off guard because he knows it's a fucking deep conversation.
He wasn't ready for it.
You're ready?
All right.
And just say,
listen.
Um,
I know you're concerned about a wellbeing.
Of course you are.
You're a great debt.
All right?
But I am saving money and we're going to be fine.
I just do it a little bit different than you.
Your daughter has always wanted to go to Greece and I would rather take her now
in the primer for life.
Then bring her over there when we're both,
you know,
walking around with dentures and Keynes.
Okay,
I want her to enjoy this before we have kids and blah,
blah,
blah.
And this is what I'd like to do and I need you to respect that.
And I appreciate your comments about our finances,
but I would,
I don't,
ah,
how do you say this part?
I would just say,
listen,
I will come to you cause I know you know what you're doing.
But if I,
if I am having a problem financially,
which I am not,
but if I am,
you are the first person I will come to with advice.
Okay.
Until then,
I don't want to hear another fucking word.
Fucking do it.
Smooth it out.
It's basically what you do.
All right.
So that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
Um,
I got my first show tomorrow night,
um,
here in Perth.
I'm really looking forward to it,
man.
I'm going to put my hour together out here and looking forward to all the people
that I'm going to see a comic set I'm going to meet and that type of shit.
And it's going to be insane.
Sorry going be insane.
Going through Australian into New Zealand.
But when I go into Southeast Asia,
I'm experienced in those cultures.
It's just going to be unreal.
Like in China,
you had this great interview,
um,
with the guy for those other Hong Kong Gig,
and he was mentioning how Hong Kong,
you know,
that there's,
they're basically their own deal,
the other one constitution and shit.
But in mainland China as he called it,
like,
do you know,
he said recently the,
they,
they banned puns.
They banned puns and wordplay in the media,
which I know everybody else is probing in a laugh.
Like,
oh,
that's silly,
you can't make a pun.
But you know,
humor is a great way to take the piss out of the fucking people that are in
power.
Um,
and it's a clever way to do it where you can't quite get busted for it.
And,
um,
unless got a psycho,
which maybe they do,
but whatever,
but it's a way to kind of make your point and stay out of jail and start a
movement or whatever.
So they've banned that type of thing.
And I guess to,
Comedians in China are pushing the boundaries of what is allowed on stage.
And what is amazing to me over there is that in China,
the standups over there,
that art form,
which I think eventually it will go global.
It's really weird that that art form has not the fact that music,
you know,
acting and,
and all these uh,
film all pictures,
painting,
all the other arts are worldwide,
but stand up one of the great arts,
I feel that there is,
is not worldwide and it's like brand new essentially in China.
And what's so fascinating,
mainland China,
what's so fascinating to me is that they are actually pre Lenny Bruce over
there.
You know what I mean?
Like I look at these other places where they can actually talk and I'm like,
it's exciting to me cause it's like,
all right,
they're going to have their Richard Pryor,
they're going to have their George Carlin.
They're saying,
yeah,
can you send or whatever.
And uh,
okay.
You know,
these,
these guys are actually in China are like,
they're waiting for their Lenny Bruce to come along,
which is pretty amazing to me.
And,
um,
I also can't imagine living in that type of oppression,
how that would affect the comedy,
um,
on just like a whole other level,
like just listening to Richard Pryor and
okay.
What he ended up talking about because of what he went through.
I can't imagine over there.
I don't know.
It's just like a different thing.
Like there's that whole fucking experience living in a fucking country with is
like what does that three to 4 billion fucking people or something like that or
a billion people they got over there.
I just can't imagine how you would try to stand out over there.
And then he got this oppressive fucking thing where people got to stand in front
of tanks and shit.
And I know there was like 25 years ago,
but um,
I dunno.
Okay.
Um,
I think it's going to be really interesting too.
I'm hoping that some comics,
when I go to Hong Kong,
some Chinese comics will come out and I'll get to talk to them and find out
about that because the guy was actually going to,
would you actually do a Gig on main in mainland China?
And I was like,
no,
I wouldn't because I don't know how to fucking,
I've been a free man.
So I wouldn't know how to reign that in.
I mean,
I've done corporate gigs and try to tone it down,
but I wouldn't trust myself to not blurt out something that would then,
and I'd end up,
God knows what,
haven't I?
Somebody call a fucking embassy over a shit show.
I mean I don't,
I,
I couldn't handle that cause the guy was going,
do you have any advice for those kids over there?
And I was like,
no,
I don't.
Cause I,
I,
I w had a,
uh,
a privilege standup career where all those walls were already broken down.
I actually said what I would rather,
I would like to talk to him,
you know,
and hear what they're going through.
But,
uh,
hopefully,
you know,
things open up over there.
Cause I really don't think that any government,
if you fucking oppress the people,
it's just,
it's like,
it can only last for so fucking long before people have had it.
Um,
so hopefully,
uh,
you know,
Jesus Christ,
I mean,
you need government and he need fucking rules and that type of shit,
but you don't got to be taken it to that level.
Banning puns and fucking wordplay.
Give me a break.
Anyway,
so that's the type of shit I'm going to be encountering here on this trip.
Uh,
like I said,
I'm going to try to watch the Superbowl.
I figured out when the fuck it is.
I actually left and I forgot to tape it.
Um,
so I'm hoping that whatever plane I'm on is going to have the,
uh,
he's going to have the game.
I don't know what.
All right,
I'm babbling here.
Uh,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
And,
uh,
that's it.
I'll see you.